hey yo this is rashad come check me out
on the bootleg kev show talking [ __ ] to
kev
you know what i'm saying generally
making his life
way worse than it would be
all right man look bootleg cab show
special guest finally we got a new album
from this guy i feel like every time
i've ran into you for the last you know
x amount of years i'm like yo what's up
with the music what's up with the music
man we need it we need it yeah finally
we're here we're here now
and congrats on uh just the success of
the album and the tour man we're just
talking the tourists sold the [ __ ] out
man yeah
it's news to me but
congrats bro um you know i think a a
misconception that a lot of people make
including myself is that
the delay for your new music was a td
thing but it was really on you like you
you weren't done
yeah i mean no it's it's about like
when you turn it in
start rolling you can't change nothing
so you gotta take your time
going back and forth for [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying going back and
forth with your homies your team and all
that and it just being whenever i want
to do it can we get you closer to the
mic
i'm like seeing cook over there turning
it up
so for you like you know personally what
did you go through since the last album
like um because you know
to take that much time away i'm sure you
had to get re-inspired was there
personal stuff you had to get through to
kind of put yourself into another
creative place to want to do an album i
guess i'm always recording and stuff
mm-hmm and
cause
i just like doing this [ __ ]
and so we always have like a batch of
songs
and from
time to time drop the weed yeah from
time to time party fun from time to time
you'll like hear a song and it's like
this sounds like an album track
so you put it aside
and then that [ __ ] just happens
over months and then after a while you
get to a point where you're like okay i
got
five or six songs that really sound like
this album was like okay maybe it's time
for me to start making out
and that's how happy how many um
like the pool of songs that you had to
pull from to like
pick for from the album because you've
been before
songs i call them like ideas yeah so
it'll be like
songs maybe like 20
like scratches maybe like a hundred so
like a hundred ideas or a hundred like
attempts to like get something going
just doing [ __ ] in the studio i used to
take like
those sessions eight hour 12 hour
sessions and you should think man i need
to make a song
every time and it was like no just get
off as many ideas as you can
in the studio you got to go back to the
studio you might as well go back with
something
almost partially formulated something
that you like just finish that [ __ ] yeah
that's how it happens um
talk about just kind of the evolution
from album to album for you
uh sonically like where where do you
because i feel like each album has kind
of been an evolution of like you know
your first project tape whatever we're
calling it silly sylvia yeah whatever
we're calling sylvia that was that an
album
it was it was a it was a it was a
classic is what it was thank you i call
it it's a demo to me for real because
it was the first 14 full songs that i
made me and tophead went through this
thing
where i sent him stuff and i guess at
the time i didn't realize and he didn't
realize it they would just scratch ideas
and i sent him back to see what
really like what do you want me to do to
it or what do you think of that type of
[ __ ]
and but i hadn't went beyond that stage
till sylvia
and that was me getting inspiration from
everything
that i like had been around and liked
and i was emulating at the time from
everybody from outcast to tyler scarface
everything here wayne and all that [ __ ]
and then the sunstar ray is me trying to
filter out those influences
but i still like that sound and i used
to think that i had to change
sound from album to album and i'm like
i mean like all my favorite artists soul
singers
classic [ __ ] jazz [ __ ] i'm like they
make different
variations of this [ __ ] but after a
while they start making like a sub genre
from that i'm like i want to do that so
i tried that like i started building on
that with the samsaray and then this one
was like
less
like it was even more filtered out of
other influences it was like me just
really just doing my [ __ ]
so this is like more like my sound it
sounds like you gotta identify my sound
off this like versus the last project
producers would just send me like a
jazzy beat because that was like the
stereotype i feel like now this one
they'll understand kind of immoral
before right right right yeah no like yo
that i say rashad type beat on youtube
definitely has to be jazzy yeah yeah but
not but that's gonna say like this album
definitely there's more
bounce to it there's more you know what
i'm saying without losing that [ __ ]
though without losing what people love
you for yeah that was important to me
yeah and i also think too like some of
the features you picked for this album
are dope like jay worthy's dope like
super underrated
um duke is dope like what was like uh
for you like
you know having for people who you know
you're
you're you have a cult following yeah
you know what i'm saying people are like
wait people been waiting for this album
yeah so how careful were you with like
who made the album i try to
i try to trust my gut
on i guess um
knowing that there's a chord like
there's a cult following and i think
even inside of koto there's a core
amount of them that like
understand me how i feel like i
understood the artists i like growing up
and like so they got patience
not just in time but like with
experimenting with sound they're there
for a journey
like ten ten projects deep type of [ __ ]
and then there's other ones who
have an idea of me respects him but i
had to bypass that and think about man i
want i want i want to talk to some new
people mm-hmm
i want to get to know some new people
when we go on the road and i just said
not to say the same people but i don't
want to bring necessarily the exact same
crowd so that went into it
and i also like knew that like when i
put my stuff out it was going
for good or bad it was going to get some
attention and i was like why not share
with people i like doing this [ __ ] right
right right right
the
rip who did the artwork to
the homies helped me and art and pick
the tracks
and the features were just
all the homies organic and or people who
i looked up to
and reached out and met with yeah um was
there was there anything that like
almost made the album that didn't make
the album maybe a feature that came in
too late or a record that like maybe
everything
almost didn't make the album didn't make
it no i'm saying like like is was there
something that didn't make it that was
like because maybe the sample didn't get
cleared last minute every anything that
didn't make it is probably because of
sample or because it wouldn't finish
that's fair everything is like
interchangeable like i was trying to go
for
to me like a steady seven
eight if i was judging it off my head
for every one of them like every
individual song on some like nerd [ __ ]
right right right and i was when i
played it back i'm like okay this is as
long as they know six in there and they
said at averages seven eight i know if
you don't like it you just don't like it
and if you like it you're gonna love it
and that [ __ ] that's how i just went
about the whole project
yo i randomly went to chattanooga like
in
when we were in atlanta to shoot a music
video with my artist because my friend's
family has like a farm in the middle of
chattanooga
i don't even know it's like outside of
chattanooga but i drove fort overthorpe
or
dude
it's like in the middle of the forest is
where my boy's property is
but i was like next time i see isaiah i
gotta be like man i drove through
chattanooga did you eat anything like
some fast food so i'm just mad that when
you came up you had me come up here and
talk about chatting and you brought up
chattanooga that you said the only thing
you can describe it was
no no it was forest it was just a lot of
trees and and now nobody's going to
understand what challenge is about well
listen it's if you're in atlanta ever
it's a hop skip and a jump
you know it you it was like a two-hour
drive is it two hours yeah bring bring
chattanooga some tourism what what what
is there to do there outside of have
great southern food and what i did was
spice that up um i mean we just did [ __ ]
in the we did some like it's chill i
mean
it's an aquarium it's an aquarium
aquarium it's a zoo it's good for the
kids good for fam
you know what i'm saying don't bring
your [ __ ] to chat bring your family
to chat it's a family town family time
good place to raise a family if you're
doing that yeah that's fair
um you and kenny beats got a crazy
chemistry
uh i love i think kenny's probably the
most underrated producer in hip-hop when
we're just when we when we talk about
like the beast he has a cool following
no his following is insane shout out to
twitch because those twitch people are
they're a different type of dedicated
but
but he's he's a beast um talk about your
guys's just you know chemistry and how
did that relationship start man kenny
been known each other for probably like
five years
and when he first started seeing me
beats or playing me beats i ain't like
none of them and he they were like
similar to the ones that he made right
right now but like they weren't exactly
of the same he hadn't had i guess
whatever lessons he got to get here he
didn't have those all the way
but then i heard his [ __ ] with key
the project and i was like damn
i want something it reminds you i only
know kenny yeah i wasn't thinking about
kenny beach because i don't even think
rory had introduced me something like
that right and it was like a while ago
so when i'm like bro i want to get some
beats from kenny beast he's like you
know there's kenny and i'm like that's
kenny you're like yeah so i went south
kenny on the humble
and i came back and i'm like can you
help me
and then
that's wild he was he he [ __ ] with my
[ __ ] so he was enthused even like do the
[ __ ] we both tauruses so it'd be a
challenge it's a tourist connection yeah
i guess i guess it's more like a
we both like
a challenge
um
talk about this record with uzi man
uzi's obviously uh he's kind of like a
walking enigma i feel like he's kind of
like a real life like character
he pulled up to the music video like
that i i don't doubt he did i thought
i've seen him twice and i think the
first time i seen him
we were at the hip hop awards for
rehearsals like 2016.
and he was like that but he was way more
like
bouncy he's still bouncy
it was like like super young
and now it's like
it's like you just knew he came into the
room it's kind of crazy it was kind of i
don't know it's some real ain't never
been about like that it's a typo you
know i think he's got like an aura
there's very few people i've been around
that i feel like they have like an aura
that you like he's a professional
i mean yeah he seemed like a
professional he's not a nice kid too
he's not on like some like weirdo like
rapper [ __ ] you know definitely
professional yeah um on this album that
you've had like i feel like on your your
last two projects you had some
vulnerable moments like records like
heavenly father
i i don't feel like we got as much of
that on this project uh was there
wrapped around another [ __ ]
it's in there they just wrapped around
this [ __ ] i said like don't shoot
i say all her for me is like it's it's
it's just like poetry but it's a lot of
[ __ ] and there's a lot of like
all herb is really about all this [ __ ]
is about emotional like breakups and all
that type of [ __ ] it's just wrapped in
stuff that it's more about you feeling
it and if you're a nerd you don't figure
it out you know what i'm saying like i
like i said
use the word lightly like i was you know
what i'm saying writing that [ __ ] down
deciphering that [ __ ] but if you just
want to listen to music surface you
gotta listen to it yeah and i and i try
to design a music to be like that did
you go through did you go through a
breakup uh since since working on the
album no
no i mean no you just said that that
record was about you know some breakup
[ __ ] i mean it's that's the vibe you
know you go through bad
you go through qualms in your
relationships ups
[Music]
makes it more
in the moment versus how like i actually
felt
okay the way i write it is about how i
felt not
exactly what was going on
no
that's fair yeah sometimes yeah i mean
that's fair um
you know you and sizza i feel like tde
die hards we always kind of like
associate you two as like you know uh
we're always waiting for new music from
sizza and from isaiah rashad right like
we've been waiting for what says the
drop in 2017. it's been a while since
control dropped but i feel like still
living
still in the church
maybe that was [ __ ] one of the best
albums of the last decade for sure but
we i feel like you two are kind of like
obviously there's the core tde members
and then there's isaiah rashad and sizza
and for whatever reason we always have
to wait very long times to get music
from both of you guys
we came after
like
the four horsemen or whatever the [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying right and like
after black hippie and that expectation
is pretty high well especially i think
for her
being
like some r b soul pop type of [ __ ]
like she knew she had to like diversify
herself and not only separate herself
from like the boys but from all the
girls
so her ear and her critique for herself
was higher and for me i just didn't want
to sound like them without getting the
same respect
so
yeah i think like when it's j-rock absol
q and kendrick and you're the you're
like the first rapper i feel like that
kind of got brought on after this
initial success
no matter what you do you're going to
get compared to and critiqued and it
could trick to the highest level
um
and like you know even like like you
know
with reason you know like reason no
matter what like people compare reason
to kendrick i'm like they don't sound
the same at all but he'd be rapping
because he could rap just because you
know what i'm saying that's not a lot of
people can rap you know what i mean but
was that like that like how much of
getting over that hump
with the tde [ __ ] and just kind of
earning those fans where they saw you as
isaiah as opposed to like
um hey is this the new kendrick like how
tough was that
i think it's happening right now do you
think it's finally i feel like right now
like this album you're kind of separate
separation
yeah does it feel good i don't know what
it feel like i'd
i'd just be seeing it what have you seen
that's that's made you feel like like
like finally that moment's come it's
like the way people seem to appreciate
it and the way they come come about it i
don't even see people mention them in my
comments
like i'm sorry
i don't see people mentioning them like
in a comparison way in the comments
where i'm sure previously that probably
happened a lot it was like a lot of
kendrick sometimes rock but like that
was it
and it was but it was light though back
then so i knew that they had an
appreciation for my music then but like
now it's like
this is me
so
um we're like like when you go back and
like how often do you go back and listen
to the sylvia project because i feel
like that's still into it like the day
the album came out like this album did
you just go through the whole
discography yeah i saw somebody doing it
on twitter so i was like let me just do
it
yeah how does that feel to like
listening to it now because i still feel
like that's one of the more
under-appreciated albums i was like man
i suck nah you're crazy bro i was like
man i'm like this is really slow
and moody i hear all everything i used
to get critiqued about i hear it now you
hear it
you feel like finally you've you're in
your pocket like fully like as far as
like
i'm just learning it's my i go up the
projects not like necessarily like the
years or the time
because it's about the result mm-hmm
sure improve type of [ __ ] so i'm like
this is my third project and like the
fourth one should be i'm like if this is
my third one if i do six and i'm keeping
the same expectation for myself the
second sweet like that should be crazy
respectfully uh how late how long are we
gonna have to wait un until the fourth
one i mean i was rapping yesterday so
who knows i know but like you know
it's gonna be like four years i'm better
at finishing songs now so
definitely not four years maybe
like who knows maybe next year maybe not
maybe two years from now maybe not
that's fair
i don't know yeah he's i have no [ __ ]
idea i got he had a hard drive full of
music and if they decided to be like yo
let's put out an album i'm not gonna
necessarily be like no
right right right right right did you
see the new uh tattoo that anderson pack
uh he got tattooed
don't put my [ __ ] out pretty much
first of all pretty wild thing to get
tattooed but
how do like like how do you feel about
that like if you were to if you would
unfortunately pass away
don't put it out music though but just
not enough don't put it out don't put it
under a thing and make it a thing like
it's a musical okay so put it out just
not as a body of work don't edit it
don't finish the songs
just put everything up
yeah i think um we just saw that with
like pop smoke like where the first
pop smoke album after he passed you
could tell were like songs that he had
like
actually wanted to come out yeah and
then this last album
you could tell
they threw some [ __ ] together
and it's like if it's feeding the family
i understand that but respectfully just
put out my scratches man on some like
that's some art [ __ ] seeing how the
process goes people might appreciate
that in a different level like some
untitled unmastered [ __ ] right more
raw than that
um you mentioned earlier when you were
growing up there were certain artists
that you just kind of like thought you
knew everything about that you you and
you have fans like that a very small
core of your fans that are feel that way
about you who were those artists for you
though growing up master p
lupe fiasco
[ __ ] who else did i know everything
about
uh outcast both of them i i don't know
why i used to read all those [ __ ]
magazines dude me too xxl source
blaze
all that [ __ ] online
wikipedian before [ __ ] knew what
wikipedia was and all that type of [ __ ]
did you go look up lyrics and [ __ ] like
i used to always go like when the
internet first became accessible to me i
would go like on there was like those
lyric sites you go before genius i would
people i don't know what you're talking
about yeah they're still up there then
there'd be message boards where you'd
like all kinds of like yeah i would go
on there and i
i realized that people were getting
lyrics wrong it's when i started
listening to the songs more than like i
started when i hear something i'll be
doing the lyrics now
i'll be listening to it so uh what is
your favorite cast album ever
man
it floats between the first one just
because i like so southern players the
cadillac music i like that one because
how raw and fresh they were
and i like equipment because it seemed
like some prime rap [ __ ] but then stank
on you because
it like was a glimpse of what they
could do right i don't think there's
really any songs that much bigger than
bombs over baghdad i mean bombs over
baghdad is like i remember
learning the lyrics that song as a kid
like that's one of the that's one of
those songs i can sing that [ __ ] front
to back know every [ __ ] word yeah and
it's a hard song to learn me and my
homies like we all just like we at
school trying to figure out the [ __ ]
lyrics of that record that's how it was
and like and that video is writing andre
running in the [ __ ] purple grass
they were making rap songs that were
like songs composing parts there's a
whole [ __ ] guitar solo in that [ __ ]
yeah not for sure and it was like some
trippy ass like tomorrello type guitar
yeah yeah no i'm an equivalent guy
though
equipment night to me is like about as
good as rap music i think it's usually
just like the last three songs they
could have kept that mamacita papa they
could have kept that off the last three
songs on probably all their projects
together that's probably the best album
you think the last three songs on
equipment one of the albums
from southern play holistic
at aliens
equipment
stink
the last two if you take the last two or
three from their solos of peace if you
put them in a list and i'm going off my
own faith i bet it's probably it ain't
gonna be like a whole bunch of [ __ ]
singles but it'd probably be like the
best
[ __ ] to listen to
um i think that what's crazy
liberation's in there
stank loves yeah
danny life of andres in there
um life in a day i mean what um
a lot of shit's in there even elevators
is in there because they got the 96
remix
all of it you got to count on this on
the channel i just i wish i admit that
like every time i think outcasts it
makes me miss physical
packaging because i always remember it
was tight in my cd book i would have
like four pages or four seconds
right with titties every account ever
yeah they had a t aliens had a little
comic built in but like every cd had a
naked girl on it
yo that might have been that [ __ ] around
might have what got me in the comics bro
18 aliens yeah bro yeah they had like
the whole little comic might have got me
in the comments because i was like six
yeah yeah they stopped doing the nudity
[ __ ] with the love below the speaker box
they broke the
street yeah they broke the streak what
about uh lupe who i think is lyrically
uh a [ __ ] alien uh obviously
you know a couple classics uh rapping
that tetsu [ __ ] a tattoo on youth murals
nine minutes straight rapping
that sounds like that song murals is so
crazy the cool is the best one though
you know what's crazy about the cool is
i don't think it aged that well go watch
this fire
i just re-listened to the cool on a road
trip like a few months ago and there
there's still some [ __ ] on there that's
like timeless but it's like 20 songs bro
yeah there's just some [ __ ] on there
that didn't age as well as i'd hoped you
killed six and it's still like 12 of
them on there i think it's still good i
like food and liquor the the og leak
though are you really listening to
american yeah i am listening to american
yo the american terrorist three that
wasn't on an album
that [ __ ] is crazy i never heard it
he's like he's like he's like um rapping
from the perspective
of a soldier
who's about to like blow up a building
or something and he's like riding his
wife
you heard that dude it's [ __ ] crazy
and like he's talking in code and [ __ ]
to his girl like i got i can only listen
i i honestly only listen to kim i mean
luke payne i'm going to say kimbex shout
out to kimberly i only listen to lupe
when
i'm playing a video game hmm that's good
video game music i feel like you could
appreciate some like hardcore lyrical
[ __ ] while playing games for some reason
a little bit more yeah like riding
around a lupe is like kind of not you
know it's too much thinking for me yeah
it's a lot to think about but like in at
the crib doing my [ __ ] zone out i want
to hear a good story but also
sharp left master p
is another one of them artists that like
as a kid i loved it like i still love a
lot of his [ __ ] but like the music
didn't make him say um video oh yeah the
basketball
mystical was so yeah bro mr cool quits
catching charges bro yeah he got to stop
raping [ __ ] what he got to do yeah he
getting accused of getting off
he got lawyers
no he didn't get off the first time he
didn't nah but no mystical was a [ __ ]
alien
i remember when i first heard mystical
it was like uh if musicals are serial
rapists we can't talk about them yeah
well i mean i i i mean yeah allegedly
right
i think he's a singular rapist for sure
we keep making sharp lips i don't know
was he convicted of that
he did a song he did a song with a mark
ronson after he got out of jail i i
can't imagine i didn't even know well no
i can't imagine mark ronson would do a
song with him if he was out here really
i remember when mark played it for us
and he was like yo you'll never guess
what i got on the new song guys you'll
never guess he did and then he played it
and mystical's not like james brown and
i was like this type
of battery
sexual battery and extortion like he was
pimping or was he convicted
or was he convicted
it sounds like pimping
sounds like pimping
that sounds like pimping and pandering
that's all good you don't got to put the
thing on there just down you might want
to flip that around though
yeah there you go
good content oh he was forcing a
hairstyle his hair his hair stylist and
he had some great braids
he was doing what forcing his hair
stylist to perform sex
acts
well you know mystical's hair was on
point though what you mean though she
did a good job
his braids
all
were
listen i don't want you to
we're not trying to get you canceled
with isaiah rashad today i'm not going
to get counseling no yeah i appreciate
it this guy said
he said my name's bennett and i'm not in
it
i'm over here you know i'm over here
trying to figure it out too like what
the [ __ ] man oh [ __ ] uh yo um
do you have do you have any sort of
update on scissors uh project or like uh
have you heard a lot of her music she's
sitting on can you give us any sort of
window into like what that's sounding
like
can we get this or that is it good is it
bad is it i don't know i mean you
haven't heard any unreleased music right
now we're like two songs two okay how
are the two songs you've heard some how
you think scissor has a bad two songs no
i don't think susan's got any bad music
i think she's trying to figure out from
a pile of gold which one's the shiniest
hmm
that's fair
you [ __ ] with
you feel me sometimes i want to do the
lebron thing but i'm not athletic in
them
yeah who is your basketball team being
from tennessee
um i would love if the grizzlies won but
i'm more of like
i think a lot of teams fail because of
the coaching staffs
i'm not a basketball expert
so i'm more of a player so who's your
guys giannis for the past eight years
i'm not new to this you're true to this
yeah giannis kawhi
[ __ ] with chris paul
said it had to be him
i'm a sons fan so let's not even you
know what i'm saying katie
love russell
as of late new russell fan
game step all this [ __ ] lebron
lebron he gets another praise okay he
hasn't played my song i've been waiting
for him to pull that pull up where he's
in the back of the card and he starts
seeing your [ __ ]
he ain't [ __ ] with me he listens to
everything
lebron james has like the most like
eclectic taste in rap music it'll be
like future one day and the next day
it's like [ __ ] griselda album cut you
feel me yeah it's like
it's just kidding he's just playing his
kiss playlist probably do you think it's
his you think his kids i don't think his
kids listening to benny the butcher
about to say i'm 34 bro relax
you that young kid i'm 34. i thought she
was super seasick how old do you think i
am bro i thought she was like his oldest
taco bell
do i look that old
you be hanging with some old [ __ ] bro
who do i hang with this old besides him
he's really old that's one of my best
friends he's an old man
but who do i hang out with that's old i
think i just think when i think of when
i think of you i think of like old
people i just like
like a generation before me and rap i'm
like you think you think like oh look
that's he's like he's like a
quasi-rosenberg over here on the west
coast
just the old rap guy maybe yeah listen i
wouldn't say i'm like i'm how old are
you thirty-three
thirty okay because i i was trying to do
the math from the t-pain thing
you're just a little bit older than me
i'm saying but you know you seasoned
bruh so are you but you've been doing
this for way longer than me
yeah i mean i've been doing this since i
was like 17. i don't say you look old
thank you well i appreciate the uh i
thought she was a young looking old dude
now you're a old looking young dude
i'm not sure i've ever felt more
attacked on my show
and i don't know if i'm supposed to take
this as a good or a bad thing
he's like i thought you were a young
looking no dude now you're an old
looking young dude
listen it is what it is man you know i'm
not the only one
yeah
hey him he's he's like [ __ ] 50.
but you know black don't crack
respectfully it don't yeah you work out
filipinos and black people age better
than anyone if you work out yeah yeah
like i know filipino people who are like
50 that look like they're 19. if you if
you work out if you eat good
and kind of you work out do you work out
you keep saying that i'm back to it
like i came from the gym like this so
like you're a [ __ ] you know you're in
the gym no i'm just running cardio
that's it states right now i'm not i'm
not ready for weights you know i want to
hurt myself what about diet do you like
do you have any weird are you like a
vegan or anything everything that they
tell you i should go light on i don't
eat i don't eat a whole bunch of bread i
don't eat
any dairy really so anything people are
like yo don't do that you're just like
i'm good on that one i don't eat anyway
so what's your bread subs substitute
it's not that i don't eat bread it's
like i don't i only eat bread like eat
like a sandwich have you ever tried um
they have like cauliflower crust and
like uh i'm not trying to be like that
my intake of regular [ __ ] is so
like at a healthy place that i don't
what's the worst thing you've eaten this
month like what was that meal that you
felt like [ __ ] afterwards you're like
god damn it for me it was like
in and out like three days
like jollibee like 30 minutes ago that's
the filipino spot right yeah yeah
they
i still [ __ ] with jollibee it just today
didn't hit like it was supposed to be
you know i never had had it and um
crispy crispy as chicken chris my
producer's filipino and he does a lot of
stuff with the this filipino agency and
they delivered jollibee to my house
that's fine it wasn't good
but i don't know if it was because it
was in the car and this lady made a
bunch of things
right there yeah and it also kind of
threw me off because it was it was
spaghetti and fried chicken you gotta
give it a go
and i was i opened it and i just looked
at it i took a bite at the top like no
this ain't it champ i'm like it's
filipino
is is it really spaghetti or is it
dry ramen
with like tomato sauce
think about it
so because it's filipino it might be dry
ramen do they eat spaghetti
type of cereal typically
i don't know what kind of racist [ __ ]
we're getting into here um what do white
people eat
bologna
i knew that
so i'm gonna guess that i don't think
he's just killing spaghetti over there
they're not killing spaghetti they're
killing dry ramen
over here
what's the what's the fake egg rolls
filipinos like
lumpias fire well you know what i mean
it's like every time i just dabble have
a question you dump you jump
full into it i love lumpia e40 has
olympia company e40 has an everything
company
e40 has every type of liquor and he's
slang and filipino food hey interrupting
the interview to tell you about our good
friends at odd socks now as you can see
i always have my odd socks on baby you
know what i'm saying ooh shout out to my
bony ass knees um listen go to
oddssocksofficial.com they got all the
craziest socks these are the outsiders
you know what i'm saying they got
spongebob they got cheech and chong
listen breaking bad godfather
whatever you need they got it and now
they have underwear that's right you can
get your odd socks underwear the boxer
briefs are the best underwear that you
could ever fit on your ass trust me when
i tell you
these are chucky draws what you know
about top ramen underwear all right go
to oddssocksofficial.com use the keyword
bootleg kev at checkout and you'll save
20
off of of your order
underwear masks slippers
socks whatever you need they got it
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
have it check out save twenty percent
gotta respect it or would you get into
any sort of entrepreneurial situations
you know maybe you know some isaiah
rashad french fries or something or
bro if i could have
like something like a waffle house out
here
[Music]
do you miss that about being in the
south like just i like the quality of
stuff in l.a
i like the convenience and the
familiarity and stuff in itself so i
probably like
try to make something that's tasty a
little bit better than waffle house but
price is about the same yeah cause like
loki in la like as much i mean i don't
know i mean
how about this loki in the valley
because i don't want to say la because
you'll be able to find a taco truck in
la but like the all-night food is very
it's over about nine o'clock it's weak
you would think there'd be the ill fire
like it's four in the morning we're
leaving the studio
in arizona we have a place called
filibertos what's just burritos all
night and out in the south and then we
also have waffle house in arizona but
like waffle house is like
[ __ ] i'm the type i used to be the
type that i would travel for that
for waffle house yeah yeah like i go
carl state lands for that wah-wah is
amazing and it's very slept on and you
know what i like about waffle house is
when you're really shit-faced and you're
at a waffle house it's like 3 30
sometimes you see i feel you that's cool
you conversate with the people cooking
your food
because you drunk but they're right
there they're making it
like going with my grandma when i was
like i didn't realize you know when you
don't realize you're poor
and then you're going to do [ __ ] with
your grandparents or your parents and
like i was just fine then i grew up and
realized it's just like seven dollars
right i'm like that [ __ ] is
high memory quality for seven bucks baby
yeah when i was a kid i used to think
applebee's was like the fanciest
restaurant in the world i mean you just
got bad taste and then no no no because
i was like the [ __ ] you see the
commercial you know my parents was
taking me to [ __ ] bees trash no i'm
not saying that i'm saying i just was
good i would think of applebee's and
chili's
it's like fried sticks i always would
think applebee's and chili's were like
expensive restaurants like man
i hope one day i get to go to applebee's
chili's when they still had
country stick i i take it as a
two and a half star applebee's for sure
two star but applebee's you get the two
for 20. that's why i mean
okay if it's fire i don't need it i
don't need a coupon it's not a coupon
it's just what they do it's a it's
basically you ever
yeah i mean you know you're at a certain
point in life when you take a girl on a
date it's couponing everything
applebee's two for twenty two finally
everybody gets regret and they get half
half-price appetizers during happy hour
at applebee's by the way there's no
applebee's anywhere near here it pisses
me off
it's frustrating
i kind of am free plug
cut the check applebee's goddamn it
uh what's your biggest vice in 2021 man
buying pants
what kind of pants
cargo
something like i don't know rifle orders
and [ __ ]
i try not to go into some like super
bag i just like nice pants so you're
just a pants guy
when you see me you've always got some
nice pants on every time nice
shoes i'm not a shoe guy pants
pants it's a special kind of guy i like
my pants lupe was a pants guy
taste mmm lupe i remember lupe put me on
all kinds of japanese
[ __ ] yes they're okay the rest of it
don't really matter you know it's the
opposite kind of take too cause most
people don't care about their pants it's
me in the pants
[Music]
and the rest is just an accessory but i
need the pants
what's the most expensive pair of pants
you've purchased
i don't know maybe like six hundred
seven hours i'm gonna be doing that type
of [ __ ] i'm a regular dude like i'd like
to dress like the manager would you go
to h m to my pants rappers huh would you
go to h m in my pants
were they paying me to be there no no
like if you were like hey look i need
some pants oh look there's an h m let me
go get some because they're like 19 i
usually have pets they have pants here
i'm a little bougie so so you should see
but you just said you weren't that kind
of guy
no no no no i'm not above it
would i um so you're bougie but not
bougie would i would i if i didn't have
to hmm
okay see
what kind of pants right now what do we
got
right now i got on some
grizzlies
shorts oh you got the yeah yeah yeah
vancouver grizzlies by the way i was at
the i was at the gym those are great
shorts
quite possibly top five uniform ever
yeah until you play it on 2k too much
and you just kind of hate seeing it
is that that's like your go-to on 2k
john moran and [ __ ]
valentine's just like
if if russ could shoot a little better
yeah about to say because john's not a
great shooter he's better than russ
though but that's crazy right just think
about that could shoot yeah ten percent
better than what he shot
where is he at in the league right now i
mean there's been years where he's shot
ten percent better than he shot the last
few years and he was the mvp but you're
always looking at that [ __ ] go
up like
is it for the phone
oh yeah yeah same thing with john moran
john is disrespectful to his body like
i'm afraid he's gonna like have like a a
moment where he [ __ ] himself up because
he has no fear
just jumping over [ __ ] he'd be
flying but when he shoot
it's like
ain't got to look it might it's going to
drop
maybe if it's open i know scenarios is
going to drop but rusto
if he ain't in a rhythm it's like you
just watching it and it's scary dawg
he's like playing with your heart
is it like uh wha what is kind of the
correlation in relation to like memphis
and chattanooga as far as like distances
it's pretty far i've been a memphis like
four times in my life well i'll say
atlanta's closer yeah
because memphis kind of got rap music
right now i love memphis music yeah
memphis is on fire right now yeah but
like i ain't never
i ain't got no relatives out there like
a reason to go did like memphis's scene
bleed over to like your you you like
what you liked and what you kind of came
up listening to obviously three six
mafia yeah it was awesome
i would i didn't go there often we only
went there for what since you called me
tuscaloosa oh isn't that a college town
uh no no no it's right outside of
memphis we only went there to gamble
without us i went to i went to memphis
like four times with my parents out with
my parents and grandparents i went
through that [ __ ] like all the
time yeah just driving always [ __ ]
gambling not my parents you were a big
gambler no i picked my uncle
are you a gambler
no
no
no
never no someone put you in a casino you
got a hundred let's say that they give
you a hundred bucks your money yeah it's
my money i said hey look i'm gonna give
you a hundred dollars but you gotta
gamble it what are you gonna play yeah i
was running it what are you gonna run on
though you're gonna go to blackjack
it don't matter to me if it's some [ __ ]
i didn't earn i might throw that [ __ ]
away i might give it away
and i feel it feel that way about my
possessions it's kind of crazy the only
thing i really keep is [ __ ] that like i
covet
exactly
what do you covet
what's the like what's the most random
thing at your at your house that you're
like this [ __ ] i lost my rolex so
nothing
wow yeah how do you lose a rolly
weird night
bad night
not bad night never have a bad night
weird night uber did you leave it like a
chick's house or a weird night
can you tell us a story
weird night let's let's end the
interview with this this the night of
you
no no tell what the [ __ ] happened man
was there a missions involved did you go
to the clermont lands in atlanta and
some old lady took it off you what
happened
man i hear about that man you heard
about that [ __ ] weird night
which one the one you explain i've had
some weird nights i had some really bad
really weird nights but let's talk about
it no you tell me it's yours and then
i mean most of my weird nights have been
off edibles dabs or shrooms your sounds
way more interesting tomorrow so what
happened to your what happened with you
was your rolex stolen or did you lose it
anybody gonna steal [ __ ] from me so they
didn't so did you should you i mean you
know you never know you know you hear
everybody
okay so i didn't get so you misplaced it
yeah some [ __ ] you have a hunch on where
you misplaced it this weird night
somewhere
okay this is being very vague whoever
finds it keep it
is there any sort of markings like is
there like a [ __ ] you know
like a
tde logo and it etched into the back
that's it engraved of course not
he said who the [ __ ] i don't know the
[ __ ] label
hey if your girl if your girl if your
girl gets you tattooed on it and instead
of tattooing your name she gets your
logo tattooed
[Laughter]
what do you think do you think she's not
sure about like how it might happen or
do you think she just likes your logo
more than your name i have no [ __ ]
idea that's an interesting i don't know
so you're asking if my girl were to get
my logo instead of my name yeah
would that mean she likes
walk me down this path again
do you think like to me like would you
think it's like
she's like she's willing to take that
risk
but not willing to sign them in line
right there mm-hmm
i mean i'm married so
she signed your name yeah you oh wait
one it's kind of ghetto to get your name
tattooed that's together no offense to
anybody my wife's
we've already established some ghetto
but continue i go to applebee's that's
kind of corny i go to applebee's this is
corny yes that is corny [ __ ] [ __ ] wow
man that's like it's like you had to
have no nurses like you were a freshman
in college oh we got married
when uh we got married four years ago
okay how long you know
probably like six years
how long you had to take
i got the tap before we got married
how long ago was it listen man [ __ ] you
isaiah rashad
damn
wait whose name's tattooed on your
[ __ ] head taylor
who's that it's not even business it was
a weird night
wait do you have a female's name
tattooed on you who cares oh and i mean
you're calling me corny we're both corny
then
that [ __ ] that shit's close closer to
your face i could cover this [ __ ] up
nobody sees that i can't see that i
can't get that you can't see it unless i
show it to you
you gotta hide this i put [ __ ] gloves
on bruh see it exactly i could [ __ ] i
could take my [ __ ] up like a goddamn
basketball player you know what i'm
saying your [ __ ] is behind your ear you
got to grow your hair out bruh
where's taylor at now throw your hair
out where's taylor at now
oh is that taylor yeah oh is that you
yeah oh okay okay let's you know then
you get the pass i was gonna say is
taylor around right now well she's in
the same room so you're not
is that corny that he got your name
tattooed on him
i was [ __ ] like 22 though
so you guys are like
you're like 34. i'm like 24. i was 24.
first of all i'm a grown-ass man i knew
what i was doing okay girl that's bad
decisions second of all
you're gonna go by you continue you and
i are both
like
you and i are both the same we each have
a tattoo of the girl we're still with
right you got married like you didn't
have to do that like she's just waiting
for you to marry her this was like this
is the whole dog she just said she's
waiting she said you're right this gave
me like three years that you didn't have
all right so since we're doing this
when it's like like what
so so you did this as like a uh here
this is like a
this will buy me three more years until
i have to wait but i ain't ready to jump
off the porch
so
that was eight years ago
this is like four years ago okay but
you've known your girl for how long
i kissed six tomorrow
so
like seven eight
hmm so when are you gonna when are you
gonna pop the question man i'm just
putting you on the spot i'm 30 and i
wasn't getting married before i turned
30.
so now you're technically in marriage
territory because now you're 30. i got
an album i got like another album
that's a wild knowing you you're not
gonna get married till he's [ __ ] 40.
he said yeah after the next album which
is going to be in 2029
this is guys the [ __ ] chattanooga dr
dre making his weight like it's a
[ __ ] detox every four years
jesus
well taylor turned the tables shout out
to taylor she's here your lovely your
lovely wife she's wife by proxy you know
in eight years that's wife she's your
wife
i got so i was i always hit you with i
would let you go that's all good listen
it's cool
hey listen we're both in amazing
relationships and we both have our
amazing women's name tattooed on our
body i think the only thing that will
make this more interesting is if reason
was here and pat oswald
as well um
yeah reason i don't know what made that
i mean
we just have to do it okay
[Music]
can we eat shrooms first
yes all right
it's a deal
it's a doozy
isaiah rashford
i'm down
yeah tell the uh tell that 50 year old
[ __ ] over there to set it up no
i want you to find pat oswald is pat
who's pat was that the comedian dude you
look just like him oh that's the um
that's the fat comedian guy right you're
not fat
and you're not that but you know what
i'm talking about he's like a comedian
right oh yeah yeah yeah he's like he's
like one of those he's a legend well
he's like one of those faces you see in
shows and you're like i know that guy
because he's in there famous he's like
somebody famous
yeah but i'm saying he's like a guy who
i can never think of his name you only
know like six famous [ __ ] names the
rest of them are just faces
yeah so he's famous you know george
clooney yep brad pitt took you a long
time to this thing with brad pitt from
leonard leonard dicaprio nah leonardo
had to do some [ __ ] i don't think so i
don't think okay i don't think i did at
first i was like maybe because they're
white
maybe because they're white i don't like
like they they i you know they always
say white people look the same they do
and then you talk to like you talk to
like some people and they say all asian
people look the same
i think because i'm racist no no no i'm
saying that like i think everybody
understand is crazy
everyone has had somebody say that a
race everyone looks the same they do and
since i'm a part of that race i'm blind
so like a brad pitt and leo i can
distinguish that they're different
people the [ __ ] kind of look the same
what like sometimes leo looks like a
child they look related leo looks like
an old ass child leo just started
looking like an adult exactly 50.
brad pitt is like a season like brad
pitt i think is like a guy like 60. yeah
but i think brad pitt's the kind of guy
who like leo i think
i think clean cut i think brad pitt
could have bo and it'd be all right
if that makes sense
no like if i sat next to brad pitt and
he had like a natural aroma i'd be like
it's brad pitt of course he doesn't
tell somebody about it yeah but yeah
yeah i [ __ ] sat next to brad pitt
that might smell kind of funky but it
was brad pitt so i you know
you know like matthew mcconaughey just
said did you bag the air
no
matthew mcconaughey just said he hasn't
wore deodorant in 35 years matthew
mcconaughey another white guy they all
look the same he's the one who whose
nose isn't broke right
i don't know he's got a he's going to
like on wilson but with his like with
the not broke nose yeah yeah i love him
just started appreciating you see how
you're saying all white people look the
same
they're variants you watch loki yeah of
course
it's like there's like they're we're
watching the multiverse
like the first time it broke with white
people
the only person that doesn't have a
variant is like angelina jolie that's
why i'm pretty sure she's not all the
way white she might be an alien too or
she might be angelina jolie um
her dad's jon voight so that's that
might have he's a weird guy is that
really her dad or dude or she just did
she just come out and jolly
if someone told you she was an alien
like would you be surprised
no yeah she's one of the ones like i
think if elon musk was alienated yeah i
think she hates everybody and she just
participates
she has some weird
interesting relationships with billy bob
thornton relationship billy bob they had
relationships with her
[Music]
you gotta look at who's out on top right
now
who's on top i ain't watched um that
[ __ ] santa claus movie in a couple
years no disrespect to him what
that's hannah oh bad santa oh yeah no i
mean billy actually [ __ ] it i'm
dissing that [ __ ] and hit that first
season of fargo fire first of all the
first like three seasons of fargo were
crazy but he was like the devil yes
people don't you see you [ __ ] with fargo
on fx not a lot of people do
and the coens brothers are my favorite
directors ever
do you love you love the big lebowski
yeah it's my favorite movie ever the
duke yeah it's my favorite movie ever
was
my [ __ ] from armageddon
was he actually in the movie
which one he's the guy he's like the
only white guy in hollywood who if he
fixed his teeth we get less rose
oh steve buscemi yeah steven shimmy yeah
he's like he keeps his teeth like this
yeah he's donnie he's donnie yeah he's
donnie yeah he's dying right now no his
name's donny in the big lebowski oh shut
the [ __ ] up donny
i'm like what bro
yo butchemy though is like one of my
favorite actors ever he's died
he's another guy who's like uh was he in
there was he in that movie you ever
heard of that theory was he actually in
it he was in the beginning was he
like was his character
there there's a theory that he was never
there like that he's a part of like one
of nigga's imagination
oh you're talking about in the movie
within the movie that donny never was
real theory that he's that donny's
character in that movie his character
was actually a figment of their
imagination
he was neal right his name was donnie no
the other one uh it was it was walter
walter he was he was part of walsh's
imagination i could see that because
shut the [ __ ] up donny
you're out of your element
yeah like they were saying they were
saying like the dude doesn't directly
talk to him really in the movie at all
that's i mean
it's always walter yelling at donnie and
that's why i like that's why i started
getting into the coin but then they
spread donny's ashes out of the folgers
can at the end and the ashes go into the
dude's mouth
so i think donnie was real donny they
say like donnie died
he did die like in the movie yes he
watched like that before so no he dies
lately
he literally dies i think that's what no
there's there's an explanation about
that out there
there's an explanation to it
because he talked about fargo and
cohen's brothers the coen brothers did
fargo some of my favorite directors it
was something about the dude was just
participating
with walter doing some crazy [ __ ]
there was no done
i mean i i
i'm i mean i'd love to talk to the coens
brothers and figure out if that is a
thing
i almost went to lebowski fest one year
but it's kind of corny
i had to draw the line in the sand there
i [ __ ] with uh that's right that's how i
got into it you like burned out the
reading of course burn after reading
slept on movies [ __ ] up slept on it's
like the dumb it's like the like when i
say the dumbest thing in a good way it's
stupid dumbest i've ever seen in my life
it's random as [ __ ] brad pitt's dumb as
[ __ ] yes like wearing that [ __ ]
little for this looking headphones yeah
that's like
i guess that's one of them one of the
times where i guess i realized maybe
that's like a movie that actors would
like to watch no country for old men is
that shows range of those guys man
what's that
uh they're saying walter is struggling
with ptsd after his service from vietnam
war and donnie perhaps is a friend that
walter lost and is now able
i can see i mean yeah i mean obviously
obviously walter has ptsd
obviously my dog's name is lebel saw the
[ __ ] cowboy come back in like the
last season or season before last of
fargo i the chris rock season i didn't
watch
it was i watched the first two or three
so i watched the last season i watched
was the one where they accidentally
killed the girl in the uh the the lady
or they accidentally killed a girl in
the garage and then put her in the
freezer
killed the dude or the dude yeah it was
a dude and then yeah um that was like
the second season i think it might have
been season 3. that was three
three yeah with the couple yes with the
couple that's the last one crazy yeah
season one is crazy though that's what
it was
no which was that the one with the uh
podcast brandon welcome
you [ __ ]
the brothers it's when they it's it's
two brothers yeah the brothers they play
the twins
and one of them got the girlfriend
um that's
the one
and so he the cowboy from the big
lebowski or something is in they like
redo the same scene
it's like making everything connect like
fargo's in the big lebowski like they're
in the same universe i like that in
bernard what are you what are you
watching right now though that this is
good
you know what's fire is um successful
succession and suicide squad is fire i
watched inception over here
inception yeah i never still have not
watched it i feel like i got someone
kind of ruined it for me and i just was
like all right uh i'm good i don't need
my brain to figure out if i ever want to
meet if i would ever like be able to
speak to christopher nolan because i'm
like this is the [ __ ] to be on your mind
like what's wrong with him or like
what's wrong with us um
i'm like that must be who's your
favorite director
uh
because i'm a nerd yeah
tahiti waikiki did i say his name
tahiti why
kiki
he did [ __ ] thor the third the second
one
he did ragnarok he did
what we uh what we doing in the dark the
vampire movie
i haven't seen that but ragnarok was
amazing what else he did he did um
bojo or jojo's rabbit
rabbit i haven't seen that one he's like
quirky but like deep is [ __ ] serious
i mean i love dragon rock ragnarok's
like probably my third or fourth
favorite uh marvel movies he's probably
my favorite director or whoever wrote
forrest gump whoever did forrest gump i
don't even know who did that who did was
that
is this that
never asked right who did it for his
girl tom hanks get way too much credit
for that [ __ ]
no offense what do you think tom hanks
thinks about chet hank signing to
soldier boys sodmg
he probably as a parent you think he's
proud
probably like man you're on bro you
signed with the we signed with big
dragon when you work your whole life i
think if you work your whole life
to uh to create a pathway for your kids
to do whatever they want to do he
literally wants to be a rapper
and speak patriarchal and [ __ ]
like
did he get that [ __ ] off like
the thanksgiving is going to be better
than last year
he got his sod chain he got a soda
like tom or soulja boy first rapper
to be in tom hanks house
he's coming
that photo is coming oh
that'd be great
well listen is this album coming up
i hope not who's soldier boys soldier
boys out album's coming out shout out to
him i'm doing a party with him tomorrow
in phoenix why did i just know you knew
i know his manager i mean he's been here
leave me with soldier
huh link me with soulja boy i want to
meet him he's a hero i just want to say
i met soldier
that's easy i want to be the first
hazard to be soldier you'll be the first
isaiah ever shot to meet soldier boy i
don't know you think that's a pretty
common name isaiah rashad somewhere in
the world there's there's there's i mean
it feels like there's there's a lot of
isaiah
any type of it that's all kind of [ __ ]
up but i'm like kind of like i was like
riding my own little flex it's just
tight do you have any any people out
there getting your tat like name
tattooed or anything people tattoo my
face on them is that weird
is that [ __ ] weird i don't understand
why anybody would tattoo the sun's tyrae
like the little guy yeah on them that's
kind of fire that's like different than
like your face
it's tattoos i know that they're going
to cover up one day
but your actual face is tattooed on
people's bodies like a cartoon version
of my face yeah
it's weird
yeah cause i would like talk to tech
nine and i'd always be like bro how do
you deal with all these juggalos with
like your face tattooed on their body
next to like the hatchet man it was just
part of the world i guess you know it is
i'd just be like you're gonna regret
that
probably
but we're not gonna regret our tattoos
of our lovely women's names that we have
i'm trying to get it like i'm trying to
get a ring so i can like low key cover
and stuff i feel like this is a decision
you got to swap them out so you get okay
okay okay let's let's let's figure this
out so i made this decision on like 25
so this this decision was gonna put our
logo over there instead of us getting
married
instead of instead of us getting married
here's your name tattooed on me so you
know it's real once we get married i'm
covering the tattoo up yeah because you
got the ring
swap them out swap it it's like either
or which one would you want it's
contracts it's like right now we're
rolling over at 30 we're rolling over in
the free agency
we're thinking about well we're
restricted free agents though so we're
thinking about
what the rest of our lives are going to
be like the next next 10 years you think
so non-married people are restricted
free agents if they're in relationships
unrestricted free agents nobody when
you're going through those life barriers
and you coming when you like when you
walk into a room and [ __ ] is like oh
so y'all ain't married that lets you
know that you're in restricted free
agency it could go to hell any day but
it'll also be pretty straight you still
playing season's still going on so
you're you're in restricted free agency
but it's like because we got to make
that decision type of [ __ ] it's never
going to be anybody's decision it's kind
of like kawhi
there's nothing nobody's going to know
why everyone knew he was gonna resign
with the clippers right you know what i
mean did they though i mean
the last couple days was like ah
everybody's cap space was eating up
nobody had any [ __ ] money to sign him
yeah it seemed like all the sites like
you look out there it's like yeah it's
like if you leave with that's like the
only babish out there that's interesting
he's one of your favorite players
because he's just uh just a very boring
guy not boring to watch now he has a
very good taste in music i didn't even
know that does he a good curator
had
i think anything beyond that we got a
paper to be here there it is and so
isaiah rashad
the new album is out
the tour is going to be crazy 48 cities
man